we have a voicemail number the number is
two one nine two david p i find today's
voicemail really depressing because
there's a lot of stuff related to this
going on behind the scenes take a listen
hi David love your show my name is Steve
from California so I've been watching
your show on YouTube for a while now and
I've noticed that you have to
consistently qualify every statement you
make with criticizing the left or
something similar
he told si Gabbard or Bernie Sanders or
Elizabeth Warren or what have you and
yeah you said people send you irrational
messages or unsubscribe and get upset so
my question is how do we solve this
problem of people not being able to have
rational conversations and listening to
models criticism perhaps or just
different viewpoints yeah I think it's
pretty outrageous that you have to go to
these lengths for your own audience it's
really akin to talking to children and
even in this case where the people
writing you likely largely agree with
you yeah so just wondering what your
take on that is but leather show and
thanks listen I don't have the answer
and I I think it's important to say this
is a small percentage of my audience but
it is a loud percentage of my audience
and yeah I mean listen I say Warren's
leading the polls and I get absolutely
destroyed
I say Bernie is stronger on money out of
politics and I get absolutely destroyed
because I'm picking sides or whatever
you know I'm doing the best job I can to
tell you what the facts are and to
interpret the facts as best as I can and
so there's there's two ugly sides to
this there's the political side which is
stuff like that there's also you know
many people I think one of the
criticisms of evangelicals who vote for
Trump is that they a spat claim to
espouse certain values and then they
don't vote them I don't want to do that
so one of the things that I do on this
program is as a business owner I try to
actually live the values that I espouse
I think people in the US are overworked
they need more vacation for example so
we take vacations on the show the staff
gets time off and just the other day I
got a message from someone I guess a
leftist who said I love what I love the
show love almost everything you say but
you guys take too much time off and I'm
cancelling my membership I'm still gonna
watch this stuff but I'm not gonna give
you any more money because I just don't
think you deserve it I'm a business
owner and I don't take any vacation and
I didn't write back because I'm not
gonna engage in this stuff but it is you
know when I read that I hear that what
what the person is saying is I need to
have a better work-life balance what
kind of person would I be as someone who
politically is advocating a better you
know worker time off and resources and
better treatment of workers if then I
say we're gonna work through the year
and we'll have three days off at the end
of the year right I mean it's like we're
not gonna do it and if you're gonna
cancel your membership for that or
you're gonna cancel your membership
because I reported polls I see it all is
kind of part of the same problem and
unfortunately I do not know how to fix
it I can only keep doing what I'm doing
and do it the best way I possibly can we
will probably talk more about that and
many other things on today's bonus show
the bonus show is available to paid
members and two patrons paid members can
sign up at join pakman.com patrons can
sign up at patreon.com slash david
pakman show we will talk about a
crackdown on fake Statue of Liberty
tours after alec baldwin fell for the
scam we will talk about the rise of
virtual reality for employment training
and we will have a truly horrible story
about a Mexican mayor those stories and
more on the bonus show look forward to
speaking to you then